it's true that Trump for let's say blue
collar conservative white voters there's
nobody can be like Trump no one I mean
like Trump has a magic with this group
it's not an insignificant group of
people by any measure but the question
for those people is going to be do you
want to vote for the guy you love but
who's likely to lose or join to vote for
somebody who you like but is
significantly more likely to win we're
sitting here in Florida uh you guys are
going to have an election the next
couple of years uh the governor of this
state Ron DeSantis is very likely to
challenge Donald Trump for the
nomination who do you back into Santa's
why because do you want this from the
why not Donald Trump or the why Ron
understand
yeah I mean they're they're two two sort
of angles first of all I'll preface this
with whoever is the Republican nominee
I'm a conservative I'm very likely to
vote for them now as between DeSantis
and Trump we'll start with the
shortcomings of trump he's 76 years old
he has no ability to control his mouth
or his typing fingers he has no sort of
actual plan to win I mean he literally
complained in 2020 that he was robbed of
the election through voter fraud but no
one will ask him a simple question how
do you plan to Rob the election in 2024
right like what's your plan for victory
he I did ask that of his former deputy
assistant
well you people will have to wait and
see okay yeah I'm curious
um the the he's he's trailing in every
swing state poll he he is um wildly
unpopular with Independence he's wildly
unpopular with women he has an approval
rating last I checked in the 20s and he
is 76 years old and he already served a
term I mean that that is that's a pretty
formidable list of reasons why you don't
nominate a per and he lost to the guy
who's going to run on the Democratic
party side already by seven million
votes and by the available data he will
probably underperform how he performed
in 2020. at least with again one of the
hardest things in politics is to switch
somebody's mind saying that millions of
people yeah you voted for me in 2016.
then you voted against me in 2020 and
now I want you to switch back and vote
for me that's not even switching Minds
once that's switching mines twice that's
that's super difficult so you know that
that's a hard thing
um you know and that's putting aside All
The Oddities and all the rest of the
scandals and all that kind of stuff the
case for DeSantis is that DeSantis is
extremely meticulous about how he
approaches politics you see for example
there are no leaks from his campaign
because he actually staffs up correctly
as opposed to Trump who's going on Truth
social and bashing somebody he hired as
an idiot every other day he hired them
just hands his actually doesn't have any
leaks he hires a team he's very
meticulous about it when he focuses in
on issue he really focuses on an issue
he is good at actually governing so the
the dirty little secret about Florida is
to really well governed state right we
have all the cultural War stuff that
makes the national media but the stuff
that doesn't make the national media is
that when there's a hurricane we're
rebuilding Bridges within like a day
right that the problems actually get
solved here that distance has brought
down crime rates dramatically that he
offered police officer a 10 000 stipend
to move into the state then in in the
State of Florida if you have a kid who's
going to to school you have available to
you now as of July like an 8 000 School
tax credit so you can actually take your
kid out of a public school if you want
to and move them to the local private
school if you think that that's a better
school I mean these are very good things
for people who are living in the State
of Florida which is why it's the number
one incoming state for populations he's
very good at just like the pure
governance of it and then on sort of the
cultural warfront he's taking on a lot
of the culture wars in a way that really
animates the base the base doesn't want
a Mitt Romney type who's going to be you
know sort of double Stitch water really
glossy they want somebody who's willing
to get in the trenches and fight which
is why he's very popular in the
primaries right now because the media
chose him as sort of its opponent and
that was over coven where he happened to
be right and the left happened to be
completely wrong on that using Andrew
Cuomo whose two missions in life were
killing old people and grabbing ass and
he ran out of old people you know the
the
DeSantis has has you know his governance
during covet keeping the state open keep
the economy running was against all of
what the media was saying and he
succeeded with that so that that's a
really good case for this answers now
listen their flaws with the statistics
to Canada he's not nearly as sort of
magnetic As Trump because no one is I
mean Trump is just like it's a he's been
on TV for years and years and years and
years and the camera's just drawn to him
um I you know I think that the battle
for for Trump is going to be between the
fact that he's magnetic and the fact
that he's extraordinarily tiring like if
you see him too much everybody's just
like oh like I can't I can't with this
and for the census the battle is going
to be how do you keep people interested
because he's very pugilistic but he's
like an amazing speaker or something
he's not super personable Trump's a big
people person he likes ripping people
you know and giving them a hug and he
likes or at least shaking their hand he
likes going out in public he likes the
adulation he likes interactions that's
not to San Francisco sense this is a lot
more kind of reserved as a person and so
that's that's an uphill battle for him
but he also knows how to run a
government and if he gets into the
presidency then he presumably will not
allowed the quote unquote deep States
thwart him he'll just go on a fire a
bunch of people he was in Congress he's
been a governor he knows how to run
things so that's the case for DeSantis
and I think also against Trump and what
would you say to those people who say
DeSantis simply doesn't have the cut
through with ordinary people like Trump
does uh I mean I don't know who the
ordinary people are so I think that
that's that's it's true that Trump for
let's say blue collar conservative white
voters there's nobody gonna be like
Trump no one I mean like Trump has a
magic with this group it's not an
insignificant group of people by any
measure but the question for those
people is going to be do you want to
vote for the guy you love but who's
likely to lose or join to vote for
somebody who you like but his
significant more likely to win and that
really is going to have to be the
question for people I mean I I had this
conversation with the guy the other day
and he's like yeah I think to Santa's
has a better shot there's Wall Street
Journal poll that came out this week
that says the same thing 41 of
Republican voters say DeSantis is more
likely to be Biden 31 say Trump that
same poll showed 51 voting for Trump in
the primaries versus 38 for DeSantis
it's like who are these 20 of people who
don't think that that Trump is likely to
win but will vote for him in a primary
who are those people like that's such a
weird thing you're going to vote from
him in the primary knowing that he's
likely to lose like that seems that
seems very strange to me I think that
people have to get over this um this
sort of
weird dream-esque equality that they
have about Trump which is that he's sort
of a miracle worker and again I think
that that actually goes back to 2012. um
because in 2012 when Romney ran and
Obama was unpopular and Romney lost the
Democrats decided they were never going
to lose another election and Republicans
also thought Democrats are never going
to lose another election they've built a
new minority majority Coalition with
some college-educated white people
they're never going to lose they've got
this thing from here on and that was the
theme for Hillary and then Trump wins
and everybody's brain just breaks the
left goes it must have been the Russians
the Russians must have stolen this thing
the right goes he must be a wizard I
mean there's no way for us there's no
way for us to win I mean look at this he
he lost by you know three million votes
but he pulled exactly like right in this
place like uh you know the the bolts hit
from Zeus and suddenly he's president
like that's the man works miracles and
then 2020 happens and now the
presuppositions are challenged again so
the left goes well maybe you know our
Coalition is more durable than we
thought it was in 2016. and the right
goes well maybe he's not a miracle
worker and then Trump says I didn't lose
well maybe he's a miracle worker who got
who got stiffed right he's still a
miracle worker and so the question for a
lot of Republicans is going to be do you
still think he's a miracle worker do you
think that he's being jobbed or do you
think that like political gravity
applies and he won one election and then
he lost like three elections he lost
2018 he lost 2020. he lost 2022 like
that those are those are three elections
he did not do well
foreign